[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous
bienvenue dans votre recette 8 dans
l'actualité de ce jeudi 21 septembre il
planait comme un air de Festival de
Cannes au château de Versailles hier
soir mercredi 20 septembre le roi
Charles III et la reine Kamila on dîné
dans la galerie des glaces avec le
couple présidentiel Emmanuel et Brigitte
Macron retour sur cette soirée
historique et ça va swinguer jusqu'au 24
septembre sur le Golf National de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines l'Open de
France revient pour sa 105e édition et
réunie les meilleurs joueurs français
cette année des idées de sortie
également dans votre 7 8 à l'approche du
week-end Gabriel Gontier vous a
sélectionné quelques bons plans au
programme également le Théâtre de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qui fête ses
30 ans mais aussi une visite dans les
coulisses du château de maison à la
fuite et puis comme d'habitude l'invité
du 7 8 en deuxième partie d'émission
avec Florence Bergeot blackaire
anthropologue et chercheuse au CNRS elle
a reçu des menaces de mort depuis la
parution de son livre Le fréhisme et ses
réseaux qui évoquent le mouvement des
Frères musulmans elle tenait une
conférence à l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines cette semaine
Patrice karmouz l'a interrogé sur sa
situation et celle de l'université
un roi au château de Versailles Charles
III est arrivé à 20h avec la reine
Kamilla accompagnée du couple
présidentiel Emmanuel et Brigitte Macron
une grande première pour un souverain
britannique depuis plus de 50 ans c'est
la première fois en tant que préfet que
je suis aussi ému parce que c'est un
moment extraordinaire le chef de l'État
estanic la dernière fois que souverain
britannique était reçu de cette manière
à faire ça et c'était la reine en 1972
donc évidemment c'est un très grand
moment avant son arrivée 150
prestigieuses invités ont traversé la
cour royale du château pour se rendre
sur le tapis rouge parmi les convives
des footballeurs comme Patrick Vieira ou
Didier Drogba les comédiens Charlotte
Gainsbourg et Hugh Grant le leader des
Rolling Stones Mick Jagger plusieurs PDG
étaient également présents comme le
milliardaire du groupe LVMH Bernard
Arnault une soirée de dîner d'État est
une soirée importante parce que c'est la
célébration d'une amitié entre deux
peuples de chefs d'État mais à travers
ces chefs d'État c'est de nation
évidemment qui se rencontrent ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose qu'on voit pas
souvent je crois que j'en ai vu deux
déjà dans ma vie et c'est peut-être le
dernier auquel j'assisterai devant le
château des centaines de journalistes
venus des quatre coins du monde ont
suivi cet événement
historiquement symbolise l'unité entre
deux pays qui partage la culture et
l'histoire on adore ça nous les
journalistes secrétaires peut glamour ce
côté papier glacé et surtout
ce côté exceptionnel parce que si on
sait que le roi Charles III et déjà venu
à 34 reprises sur le territoire français
c'est la toute première fois qu'il vient
en France depuis qu'il est roi les
invités ont ensuite dîné dans la galerie
des glaces sur une table de 60 mètres de
long et qu'au menu du homard bleu de la
volaille de Bresse et des macarons à la
rose le repas s'est terminé aux
alentours de 23h30
aujourd'hui ce jeudi 21 septembre c'est
le début de l'Open de France de golf ici
à 50 ans en Yvelines à mes côtés
Philippe pilateau le directeur du Golf
National de 50 ans en Yvelines alors
cette première journée ça se passe
comment c'est humide c'était une matinée
humide mais qui vient se présager de
belles journées aujourd'hui les
conditions étaient quand même assez
compliquées mais bon on a eu quand même
un score de moins 7 avec Tom Tom Kim 18h
jouet 18e joueur mondial qui a fait ce
score incroyable aujourd'hui mais sinon
voilà tout est beau tout est propre de
façon à continuer la semaine les greens
sont comment balayer sont excellents en
bombe honnêtement ils ont bien répondu
ce matin c'était un bon test ils sont
rapides ils étaient à 11.9 ce matin au
steam ce qui veut dire que c'est une
vitesse une très bonne vitesse pour pour
un tournoi de cette qualité là et ils
ont bien répondu par rapport à toute la
pluie qu'on a eu ce matin oui tout à
fait on est sur cette 105e édition de
l'Open de France de golf qui va
l'emporter est-ce qu'il y a des favoris
qui se dégagent bah Tom Kim montre le
bout de son nez après derrière nous
voilà on a on a des joueurs comme comme
Julien brun des joueurs comme Antoine
Rossner pas mal mais voilà une belle une
belle escadron de de joueurs français
qui est qui est là maintenant on va voir
mais un clim ou un shell ça serait bien
ça serait bien pour le tournoi oui il y
a des têtes d'affiche justement Kim qui
est le nouveau prodige un sud-coréen
qu'on pourra voir jusqu'à ce dimanche
ici à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines c'est
vraiment l'avenir du golf bah qui mouais
c'était c'est vraiment c'est vraiment un
prodige du golf il faut effectivement on
le voit et puis on le voit par rapport à
ce qu'il a pu la qualité de son jeu
aujourd'hui dans les conditions qui
étaient extrêmement compliquées tous les
joueurs l'ont dit que les conditions
étaient très très difficiles je pense
que c'était peut-être aussi un petit
repérage par rapport à l'an prochain par
rapport aux Jeux Olympiques les Français
du coup c'est compliqué pour eux ouais
c'est un petit peu plus dur après il
joue à domicile après c'est toujours un
peu compliqué pour les Français parce
qu'après ils sont quand même très
sollicités les familles sont là je pense
que c'est un tournoi un petit peu en
particulier les concernant et c'est vrai
que ça reste quand même le sport ou
c'est un c'est important de rester dans
sa bulle et dès l'instant où il y a
peut-être des éléments un peu extérieurs
c'est peut-être un peu plus difficile de
se mettre se mettre dans le jeu cette
openo France c'est le dernier avant les
Jeux olympiques de 2024
on va dire que c'est la dernière
dernière répétition avant les Jeux
Olympiques donc pour nous c'est très
bien pour pour les équipes aussi ça nous
a permis de voir un petit peu mais voilà
dans le cadre de la préparation du
parcours parce que
préparation qui se fait maintenant poste
posté donc comme on l'a vu cet été avec
un peu de sécheresse et des conditions
qui sont quand même pas très favorables
pour pour monter le parcours à ce niveau
là donc ça nous a permis de tirer des
enseignements de façon à pouvoir
proposer un parcours incroyable en
prochain dans le cas des Jeux Olympiques
oui est-ce qu'on peut dire que déjà le
le Golf National est prêt pour
accueillir cette épreuve ouais il y a
encore du travail il y a beaucoup de
travail c'est-à-dire que là maintenant
le le focus là on finit la semaine
d'accord on finit dimanche soir on fait
un peu la fête on fête en fait ce
tournoi et ensuite à partir de la
semaine prochaine on va on va se
concentrer sur les Jeux Olympiques ce
qu'il faut c'est que c'est que le
parcours soit exceptionnel pour pour les
Jeux Olympiques et on a encore la
maintenance et ce qui est entre entre le
mois d'octobre et puis et puis fin juin
l'année prochaine pour préparer le
parcours donc on a encore du temps mais
le temps passe vite et le focus ça va
être de proposer aux joueurs au meilleur
joueur les meilleurs joueurs mondiaux un
parcours incroyable merci à Philippe
Pilato l'Open de français jusqu'à ce
dimanche ici à 50 ans en Yvelines et on
le promet dimanche il y aura du soleil
[Musique]
un lien d'amour face à la maladie Myriam
angelber 57 ans via ecuvilly dans les
Yvelines en 2019 lors d'une réunion de
famille ses proches s'aperçoivent de ses
pertes de mémoire après analyse le
diagnostic tombe elle était atteinte
d'Alzheimer précoce un moment douloureux
amplifié par le manque d'empathie de
certains médecins j'ai refusé et j'ai
dit j'ai dit non et puis j'ai dit de
toute façon moi je suis un peu une
battante quand même et j'ai dit de toute
façon je m'arrêterai jamais c'est une
prise en main moi je le vois comme tel
bien sûr etc mais moi je peux plus
prendre ma voiture et partir et puis
faire ce que je vais faire
donc pour moi je suis en prison dans ma
maison un frein dans la poursuite de ces
projets avant sa maladie Myriam aimée
faire des randonnées seules sur
plusieurs kilomètres sa perte
d'orientation du haut trouble cognitif
l'empêche de vivre ça passion en toute
autonomie je peux plus bouger je suis
dépendante tout le temps donc c'est
lourd
et puis il est prêt ben qu'est-ce qu'on
fait quand je me retrouve seule je
touche j'ai le côté tactile qui prend le
dessus comme quelqu'un qui est aveugle
alors qu'on ne l'est pas mais il y a des
sens qui sont effectivement
sont abîmés je pense c'est pas abîmé
j'appellerai ça comme endormi suite à
l'annonce de sa pathologie cette
ancienne ingénieur commercial dans une
société informatique a dû renoncer à son
poste une épreuve pour cette femme
active j'ai beaucoup travaillé depuis un
moment il y a eu des petits problèmes
mais c'est je voulais pas en fait
peut-être les entendre je voulais pas
aller voir parce que pour moi j'adore
enfin j'adore ce job course cuisine ou
sortie une auxiliaire de vie accompagne
Myriam plusieurs fois par semaine dans
les actes de la vie quotidienne une
épaule précieuse pour son mari Hervé
malgré ses difficultés accumulées son
métier de banquier avec son rôle des
dents c'est un peu le jour sans fin
ce que tous les jours on recommence les
mêmes choses
les mêmes rituels il faut il faut aider
à l'habillement il faut moins tous les
jours je suis obligé de m'occuper de
tous les à côté les faire à manger faire
les lessives
faire faire le ménage grâce à
l'association France Alzheimer Myriam
participe désormais à des groupes de
paroles entre managers un moyen pour ce
couple de libérer la parole pour mieux
vivre la maladie
cet après-midi le département des
Yvelines organisait métamorphose urbaine
le premier congrès dédié à la
transformation des quartiers
prioritaires l'objectif débattre autour
de l'aménagement et de l'évolution de
ces territoires afin d'améliorer leur
attractivité experts et les locaux
bailleurs et associations étaient réunis
au Phénix de Chanteloup-les-Vignes les
prochaines élections sénatoriales auront
lieu ce dimanche 24 septembre de quoi
s'agit-il ce sont des grands électeurs
c'est-à-dire les mers les conseillers
municipaux départementaux régionaux mais
aussi les parlementaires qui votent 6
siège sont à pourvoir pour les Yvelines
pour un total de 64 candidats retrouvés
toutes les listes en détail à la fin de
votre 7 8 la circulation risque d'être
compliquée à Élancourt ce dimanche 24
septembre sur la colline compétition de
VTT cross country est organisé en vue
des Jeux olympiques de Paris 2024 pour
sécuriser l'événement des restrictions
de circulation sont prévues comme sur la
rue de Strasbourg et l'avenue Marcel
Dassault des déviations seront mis en
place pour éviter les secteurs
mentionnés toujours en perspective des
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
Paris 2024 le Département soutient 14
athlètes yvelinois dans leur pratique
sportive parmi ces sportifs Christopher
6 cavaliers médaillé de bronze aux JO de
Tokyo Rima Ayadi championne du monde de
boxe et Guillaume chaîne mais d’ailleurs
de judo par équipe si certains sont déjà
qualifiés d'autres devront encore
patienter ce soir ne manquez pas le
retour du 15 de France pour leur
troisième match de Coupe du monde ils
affront la Namibie au stade Vélodrome de
Marseille à 21h objectif terminé premier
de la poule vous pouvez soutenir les
Bleus en direct des Yvelines les villes
de Versailles et Rambouillet vont
retransmettre le match
[Musique]
on va fêter les 30 ans non pas de la
scène nationale mais du bâtiment du
bâtiment qui a pris à la fois le théâtre
mais également le mumet c'est à dire le
musée de la ville et la médiathèque du
canal voilà la scène nationale elle a
été c'est National 2 ans avant se
termine 991 et là bougé dans ce lieu là
ce magnifique lieu conçu par
l'architecte Stanislas Fischer
ce lieu ce bâtiment est un véritable
marqueur par l'activité artistique
culturelle de l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin il est repéré y compris
par ceux qui ne font que passer ici ou
bien ceux les quelques-uns qui ne
rentrent pas encore dans ce lieu-là et
puis c'était assez
intéressant aussi cette concomitance des
dates entre les 30 ans et puis le début
des travaux de rénovation du théâtre
dans qui va commencer dans quelques mois
[Musique]
bien sûr un programme qui va se dérouler
aussi bien dans le théâtre que devant la
médiathèque du canal que dans
à l'accueil de la médiathèque puisque il
y aura la fois des performances en
projet un projet participatif chanté
danser qui s'appelle week-end be heroes
il va y avoir une installation d'une
loge ce qu'on appelle une loge à
l'accueil de la médiathèque du canal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avis au curieux et au férus d'histoire
le château de maison à Maisons-Laffitte
vous propose des visites guidées des
petits appartements du haut de la
coupole grâce à un petit escalier dérobé
découvrez des espaces normalement fermés
à la visite on se trouve effectivement
dans un des une des petits un des petits
appartements de du Château de Maisons
ces petits appartements servaient de
pièces à vivre pour des invités de rangs
moindres par rapport au roi où les
enfants du propriétaire et donc ici on a
cueillait soit des membres de la
noblesse soit éventuellement des savants
des philosophes et au début du XVIIIe
siècle c'est ici que Voltaire sera
accueilli par son ami Jean-René de
Longueuil qui était propriétaire du
château un séjour durant lequel Voltaire
a failli mourir par deux fois autre
anecdote c'est aussi dans ces petits
appartements que Mansart l'architecte du
château à ses journées ainsi que le
général paillettes est député de la
scène c'est un homme politique et un
banquier et il va être à l'origine d'un
d'un complot qui vise à chasser du
pouvoir Charles X le petit frère de
Louis XVI qui est droit à ce moment-là
et qui s'est insurrection en fait va
être lié aux Trois Glorieuses ces trois
journées qui vont pousser le roi à
quitter le pouvoir tout ça ce foment ici
et parmi les mystères du château cette
pièce accessible uniquement par une
trappe située sous une cheminée personne
ne sait encore aujourd'hui à quoi elle
pouvait servir la visite des petits
appartements du château de maisons se
déroule tous les dimanches à 14h jusqu'à
la fin du mois d'octobre la réservation
est limitée à 10 personnes maximum en
raison des espaces assez réduits
pas de doute nous sommes bien en automne
demain matin le ciel sera toujours gris
avec de la pluie sur une bonne partie
des Yvelines seul le secteur de
Mantes-la-Jolie devrait être épargné au
niveau des températures ça se rafraîchit
de plus en plus il fera 12 degrés en
moyenne dans l'après-midi nous devrions
avoir une amélioration avec quelques
éclaircies côté température il fera 16
degrés à Versailles et Rambouillet et 17
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie et Houdan et
pour les prévisions météo du week-end
samedi le soleil devrait refaire son
apparition dans les Yvelines avec des
températures minimales à 8 9 degrés et
des maximales à 18 19 degrés dimanche un
grand soleil est annoncé sur une bonne
partie du département seul le secteur de
Versailles reste quelques peu nuageux
côté température les minimales seront à
6,7 degrés et les maximales à 20-21
degrés tout de suite l'invité du 7 8
avec Patrice Carmouze
[Musique]
vous êtes venus pour une conférence sur
le thème savoir et censure évidemment ça
fait suite à la publication de votre
livre le vrai risque bicareso chez Odile
Jacob c'est ce livre vous savez un peu
commencé avant mais qui vous a attiré
des menaces de mort enfin des choses qui
qui nous renvoie une période qu'on
croirait révolu de l'Université du
savoir justement et de la censure oui
ici j'ai été un petit peu le cobaye de
cette séance puisque je ne faisais pas
l'analyse de livres du contenu du livre
mais plutôt j'ai essayé de donner
quelques éléments d'éclairage sur mon
expérience de chercheur effectivement
surprise par la violence des des
intimidations des menaces des pressions
qui continuent d'avoir lieu autour de
moi et de mon ouvrage et surtout
l'absence c'est ça qui est remarquable
de critique de fond
véritable critique de fond qui ne sont
pas encore arrivés alors il y a quelques
petites attention qui sont plutôt
favorables à mon livre mais pour ce qui
est de mes contenteurs ils n'ont
toujours pas sorti de véritables
arguments fondés sur la
conceptualisation que je propose et
c'est ça qui est un petit peu
particulier c'est à la fois cette
violence et cette vacuité de la part de
certains collègues qu'est-ce que cette
violence blocage nous dit de
l'université française de l'Université
en principe c'est le lieu en effet des
savoirs et on ne peut tout à fait ne pas
être d'accord avec une thèse mais mais
mais il y a une discussion et une
disputes quand vous disiez des
discussions qu'est-ce que ça dit
aujourd'hui c'est blocage de diversité
française l'université est mal en point
pour ne pas dire malade alors
heureusement il y a comme aujourd'hui
des résistants des gens qui
s'interrogent sur ces problèmes de
liberté académique le problème aussi
c'est que c'est au nom de la liberté
académique qu'on veut faire taire des
gens comme moi c'est ça qui est
paradoxal c'est que les ennemis de la
liberté d'expression utilise leur
liberté de faire taire d'une certaine
manière c'est ça qui est très
particulier et je crois que ce qui est
plus inquiétant c'est l'autocensure
c'est à dire le fait d'anticiper un
événement violent même s'il n'y a aucun
signe que ça va se produire comme ça ça
a été le cas pour moi lors de la
conférence annulée ou plutôt reportée de
la Sorbonne il n'y avait pas de signe
d'inquiétude et pourtant la Sorbonne a
décidé de suspendre mon ma conférence ce
qui a provoqué le
la réassurance chez certains c'est écrit
qui c'était critiques de mon livre sans
l'avoir lu c'était la preuve qu'il y
avait quelque chose
or vous êtes pardon vous êtes vous
appartenez au CNRS vous êtes une
chercheuse
reconnue même si vous êtes contesté par
un certain moment de rester je veux dire
c'est normal
contester mais sur la base d'arguments
véritable et qui prouve que la personne
l'a lu pas de Thierry picking où on
prend certains mots sur certaines pages
et on dit ah bah voyez je dis ça
complètement hors contexte non non il
faut avoir compris ce qu'a voulu faire
l'auteur et ensuite en appartient c'est
comme ça qu'on travaille en sciences et
tout à l'heure vous avez dit voilà
depuis depuis la publication de ce livre
alors votre travail universitaire est
comme devenu extrêmement difficile vous
pouvez pas avoir des étudiants parce que
ça ne gâcherait peut-être leur carrière
parce que le le secteur est tenu par une
certaine idéologie
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas aussi victime
de ce mouvement comme ça on dit pas de
Vannes quoi oui il y a le pas de
valdisme comme on dit il y a l'acheter
mais il y a surtout ce qu'on pourrait
appeler la l'irresponsabilité plus
personne ne se sent responsable la
grande machine à produire de la
connaissance fonctionne chacun à son
petit salaire à la fin du mois
les médias s'emparent de certains sujets
en font des choses complètement
différentes de ce qui a été produit
vraiment dans la reine universitaire et
puis ça continue comme ça
c'est pour ça que cette conférence l'a
montré il nous faut réfléchir maintenant
sur les moyens de véritablement protéger
la liberté de recherche et de réfléchir
ensemble avec les étudiants moi j'étais
surpris et beaucoup d'étudiants
aujourd'hui donc il s'intéresse
véritablement au sujet et ils ont raison
il faut réfléchir avec eux au moyen
d'améliorer cette situation là il y a
une chose c'est que voilà vous faites
des conférences sur sa voix et sensuelle
du coup le on part presque plus du fond
du fond du livre ce qui est quand même
dommage
il vient de sortir
je sais que en tout cas moi je suis
contacté par les Britanniques les Danois
les Suédois les Indiens aussi
s'intéressent à mon livre donc je me
fais pas de souci il va revenir et cette
fois-ci on part on parlera du fond merci
beaucoup merci à vous
[Musique]